[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 8
février
pour sa première exposition temporaire
depuis sa réouverture le musée de la
ville a choisi le vintage un retour dans
le passé à travers le n'oubliez et la
mode
les comédiens amateurs joués par des
comédiens professionnels fond de la
scène et enquête les faux british la
pièce burlesque était au théâtre espace
coluche de plaisir du théâtre encore
mais cette fois amateurs ne partiront à
la rencontre de la troupe du crâne la
compagnie fondée en 1982 est installé à
venir et un moment il y a quelques
semaines nous vous présentions le musée
de la ville nouvelle version à
l'occasion de sa réouverture il propose
aussi une nouvelle exposition temporaire
les équipes mettent cette fois à
l'honneur le vintage un regard en
arrière ni en images avec alice
deschamps allaient 60 à les 90
aujourd'hui
dur à dire le musée de la ville vous
invite dans un monde où les époques se
mélangent le vintage c'est sont tous les
objets qui datent des années 50 aux
années 90 environ qui sont des objets
authentiques souvent de marques qui ont
marqué leur époque et qui sont ressortis
aujourd'hui réutilisés pour être mélangé
à des objets contemporains
on ne fait pas une histoire de la mode
on explore la façon dont certains objets
sont ressortis des placards
pourquoi ce sont ces objets là et pas
d'autres et comment aider le visiteur à
distinguer sur une brocante par exemple
quel sera l'objet vraiment vintage
originale et une copie ou une
contrefaçon
des objets issus des collections du
musée ou de prêts d'habitants du
territoire du mobilier mais aussi de la
mode des pièces rares et anciennes à
découvrir comme lors d'un défilé
c'était un choix justement parce que ce
sont les top models qui ont diffusé
d'abord le vintage dans la mode et son
au scénographe qui ont voulu jouer sur
un module de seynod que vous retrouvez
un peu partout qui est la table lac
ikea ils ont voulu faire la
confrontation entre les pièces iconiques
vintage et cet objet qui est vraiment le
type de la société de consommation qu'on
retrouve partout qu'on jette qu'on
rachète pour
quelques euros du channel du courage des
kickers des pièces de qualité qu'on
trouve encore aujourd'hui dans nos
armoires et vous quel style êtes vous on
ouvre une page de théâtre maintenant
avec une pièce qui tourne actuellement
dans toute la france et qui a posé ses
valises la semaine dernière au théâtre
espace coluche de plaisir alors elle est
lauréate du molière de la comédie ça
s'appelle les faux british essam el une
histoire d'amour et une enquête
policière une comédie complètement
décalé jusqu'en dans les entretiens avec
les comédiens nous avons pu interviewer
les personnages regardent et je vais
avoir besoin de chacun de vos
témoignages
plus tôt je commencerai mon enquête plus
tôt c'est une enquête
un véritable cluedo fin 19ème siècle un
manoir anglais un meurtre et camille
lors d'une soirée de fiançailles
fortement pas une comédie c'est un
trailer sais c'est dur on est tous et
des fans de romans noirs anglais et
c'est comme ça qu'on a voulu à fait
interpréter cette pièce de théâtre c'est
une vraie enquête tout à fait et c'est
une très belle histoire d'amour surtout
c'est à dire il ya à la fois une on peut
parler en fait on peut dire il ya un
amour en quelque sorte incestueux et
l'aria elle parle des personnages ne
parlent pas d'évidence et donc
effectivement il ya une histoire d'amour
et il faut évidemment trouver qui est le
meurtrier alors on va pas vous le
dévoiler parce que sinon vous viendrez
pas le voir molière de la comédie 2016
les faux british multiplie les dates et
les applaudissements avec des comédiens
professionnels qui jouent les amateurs
et qui ne s'arrête jamais j'ai répété le
texte devant ma femme si je les jeux les
répéter avec ma femme
d'ailleurs n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord sur l'identité de l'auteur
c'est un peu tendu entre nous ces
derniers temps on pense que l'auteur
c'est conan doyle
voilà qui voulaient se débarrasser du
fameux personnage de sherlock holmes
en faisant ce spectacle très important
sur sur sur un meurtre de nouveau dans
un manoir au manoir avère cham si vous
avez raté leur passage à plaisir de
séance de rattrapage
le 23 février au théâtre gérard philipe
de saint cyr et le 19 avril au prisme
island
après les professionnels place aux
amateurs nous partons à maurepas pour
découvrir la troupe du crâne cette
compagnie a été fondée en 1982 par
monique fonds didion un professeur d'art
dramatique et auteur de théâtre aussi
ses comédiens foulée scène de nombreux
lieux france nous ont regardés passe
transformation bon avant et après une
heure avant le lever de rideau les
comédiens de la troupe du cra devons
jouer sur la scène de l'espace albert
camus le stress commence à monter petit
à petit c'est vrai que c'est la première
fois qu'on joue cette pièce sur celle là
je dirais que il n'ya plus qu'à laisser
venir un peu les émotions le stress qui
grimpent eux gentiment et puis on sera
prêt pour ton 8h30 cette année pour le
festival de maurepas ils ont choisi les
comptes
le petit chaperon rouge en amuse-gueule
qui font qu'on arrive à trouver
l'atmosphère le cocon dans tout ça que
ce soit comme un un nuage une chose
lointaines comme un buzz et la belle et
la bête leurs dernières créations
une plongée dans l'univers enfantin pour
cette troupe qui fête cette année ses 35
ans sa particularité
tous les comédiens sont amateurs comme
le football on a deux entraînements par
semaine et anjou le week-end
voilà donc c'est un peu ça non mais ça
nous fait du bien à tous de quitter le
travail est de retrouver un esprit où on
peut faire autre chose
j'étais professeur d'art dramatique
je me suis retrouvé ici c'était des
champs à perte de vue
et j'étais désespéré parce que l'amour
de ma vie c'est mon théâtre et si vous
voulez j'étais à la mairie tout
simplement demandé si il n'y avait pas
local susceptible de me recevoir et où
j'aurais pu commencer à faire un embryon
de troupes
j'en ai vraiment scellé par par l'amour
et la folie du théâtre parce qu'il faut
un petit peu de folie la passion et il
faut une certaine rigueur des comptes de
la poésie ou encore du théâtre de
boulevard avec une nouvelle pièce chaque
année la troupe se produit
principalement dans les châteaux
franciliens
pour notre coup de coeur cinéma de la
semaine direction le grenier à sel de
tra biel pineau vous propose un rendez
vous spécial enfants regardent cette
semaine je voudrais vous parler de notre
gros coup de coeur c'est le festival
télérama enfants vous connaissez
certainement le festival télérama ça
fait vingt ans que ça existe on a fêté
les 20 ans cette année
et là c'est la toute première édition du
festival cinéma télérama pour les
enfants et nous participons donc cette
année nous sommes très contents et il ya
plusieurs événements déjà il y à une
sélection de films de reprise des
meilleurs films delà de 2016 mais nous
avons aussi quelques quelques animations
et une en avant première je vais
commencer tout de suite par l'avant
première ce sera le film la jeune fille
et son aigle
c'est un documentaire
qui se passe en mongolie un peu comme le
chien jaune de mongolie et on suit
l'histoire d'une petite fille qui élève
un aigle pour faire un concours de
chasse allègre est dit comme ça je vous
donne pas forcément envie puisque ça
mais c'est quelque chose de formidable
ce qui est le plus impressionnant c'est
de se dire que c'est du réel
ce sera donc la jeune fille et son aigle
en avant première le vendredi 17 février
à 14 heures nous aurons aussi des
animations pour avec le film les
aventures de pâtes et mat c'est un
programme de courts métrages à partir de
3 ans il y aura une animation et il y
aura les marionnettes du film nous
aurons aussi une animation pour le film
ivan tsarévitch qui est le dernier film
de michel ocelot michel bastos était le
papa de kirikou et de azur et asmar vous
retrouvez évidemment toutes ces infos
sur notre site internet cinemacon ni à
celle points comme ce qui est très
important de préciser c'est que comme
c'est un partenariat avec télérama et si
vous achetez le magazine télérama à
l'intérieur il y à une impasse qui vous
donne accès à tous ces séances il ya
tous les films du festival pour le tarif
de 3 euros 50 comme le festival pour les
pour les adultes
ce sera donc du 15 au 28 février et
notamment au cinéma le grenier à sel à
trappes
à bientôt
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous à ne pas manquer on reste au cinéma
pour le premier le mardi 14 février
l'ugc skywest reçoit l'équipe de
patients le film réalisé par grand corps
malade et mehdi il dit raconte
l'histoire de ben gravement blessé dans
un accident regardez cet extrait genre
pompiers iv avec d'autres hommes les
toilettes c'est une espèce de rêve pour
moi dacquois tétraplégique un complèment
beaucoup un peu plus juste quoi c les
siennois soignante amodio téléphone des
sexes comme ça franchement françois on a
obligé la voiture je suis pas à mon
patient ça si tu fais ça parce que je
suis noir
à
tout respire
c'est bon comme ça tu es bien
peut-être
[Musique]
elles vendent de tetra qui se compose
comme t'as rien à branler ici règle
numéro 1 la patience compote
faut que tu commences à penser comme un
gars bien faux sur les des sports oms
si tu as envie un autre rendez vous
celui là à vivre en famille la conteuse
praline gay para vous invite à danser
chanter et rire à travers plusieurs
histoires a profité dès l'âge de 1 an
rendez vous à la maison de quartier
joseph kosma de guyancourt et dans le
cadre de l'exposition d'arlette
d'arlette vermeren à la commanderie des
templiers plusieurs poètes vont lire
leurs textes inspirés par l'artiste un
rendez vous proposés par les itinéraires
poétique à découvrir le dimanche 19
février à 15 heures un autre rendez vous
à ne pas manquer celui là il est à paris
jusqu'au 19 février le grand palais
accueille art capital une exposition
pour promouvoir l'art d'aujourd'hui
plus de 2000 artistes confirmés
exposeront et parmi eux des yvelinois
plus de 40000 visiteurs sont attendus
une autre exposition cette fois à
guyancourt à l'exposition à l'occasion
du temps des femmes
un duo mère-fille travail autour du
textile marion et sylvie breton et
réinterprète des techniques textiles
traditionnels et le détournement de
matière elle propose aussi des ateliers
participatifs
toutes les informations sont à retrouver
sur le site de la commune
cette fois on prend la direction de
montigny le bretonneux pour un spectacle
sébastien mois sierre vous accueille
dans son école de magie ce professeur
très étourdi et farfelu vous apprends
vos premiers tours rendez vous à 20h à
la salle jacques-brel de montigny le
bretonneux le 21 février regardez cet
extrait vivement
[Musique]
am agit d'abord c'est un art c'est là de
faire effectivement les choses qui
paraissent totalement impossible mais ça
sert à quoi est-ce que ça sert à montrer
qu'on est le meilleur
est-ce que ça sert à montrer qu'on est
plus forts à prendre le pouvoir sur les
autres dans la magie c'est un art du
spectacle et ça sert uniquement à
émerveiller
de la musique à présent à elancourt le
chanteur guillaume farley sera sur la
scène de la ferme du mousseau le 25
février
il est ancien guitariste bassiste
bassiste de youssou n'dour grand corps
malade ou encore un matthieu chedid il
est maintenant seul sur scène regardez
je suis l'énième bouffon avec mes
chansons
encore un qui cherche un miroir et qui
dégaine son art encore parmi des
millions qui frappe au portillon
bon bah on va y aller on va trop délire
et c'est parti pour la chansonnette mais
je vous préviens tout de suite j'écris
sur cette petite qui transforme les
bleus en poète car les chansons d'amour
et ce depuis toujours parle d'une seule
et même créature c'est le cas briser les
coeurs de milliers le chanteur écrit
quelque part dans la nature de cette
culture est maintenant terminée je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez revoir cette émission en replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application
je vous dis à mercredi prochain
[Musique]